somebody has said that the job of the
artist is to see
and then to show others what they've
seen
can we talk about moments that heal or
repair a character
i love
moments in film where there is
restoration of some kind that happens in
a way that seems
believable
that doesn't seem
shangri-la
i think about
the film blood diamond in this regard
so there's really two stories that
happen in blood diamond
we have the story of a south african
diamond
merchant
uh played by leonardo dicaprio
uh who is trafficking in these blood
diamonds i think this the movie takes
place in sierra leone
and so he's on the hunt for this giant
diamond that he's heard has been found
out in the mines that are run by
the rebel
military and the rebel military
conscripts
boys as child soldiers
both to fight for them but also to
work in these mines
the other main character is played by
jimin hansu and he's the dad
of a boy who has been abducted
and taken away from his village
made to be a soldier who commits
atrocities
so this young boy
10 years old maybe
has been made to do horrible things and
his dad
is determined to find his son
and somehow bring him back to the family
and as he's doing that he gets forced
into working
digging for diamonds
for the people who stole his son from
him and he finds this massive diamond
and he buries it
out away from the camp
and
continues looking for his son
leonardo dicaprio finds out
simon hansu's got this massive diamond
hidden
and at gunpoint takes him to dig up
this diamond
and
just as they're digging for this diamond
chime and hansu's son
shows up
and
is holding a gun on both men
leonardo dicaprio alerts jimin hansu
who's digging for the diamond
that his son is here
and so this father turns to his son who
now turns the gun to him
and
is
calling out the sons calling out for
help
and jimin hansu says
you're not one of them
you're my son and i'm your father
your mother waits for you your sister
waits for you
the wild dog who listens to no one waits
for you at home
you're not a bad boy i know they made
you do bad things but you are going to
come home to be me and be my son again
and i'm going to love you
and
in the midst of this
the father is walking toward his son
walking toward the barrel of the gun
and
the son begins to cry
and slowly lowers the gun and allows
himself to be embraced by his father
that is written directed and acted in a
way
that
you believe that
that is a moment of
restoration and recovery that maybe
shouldn't even be possible
that it would be that you could recover
a child
who has been put through those
experiences
the film presents it with a kind of
emotional believability
that
certainly represents a defining moment
for
that boy and his father
that is going to be the pivot point
certainly this kid's going to need
probably
lots of therapy and lots of love over
lots of years
to
completely
emerge from that awful darkness but in
that moment you believe
that there is real hope and
that
this
moment represents a before and after
that they will look back 10 years from
now and see that is the moment
that the healing began that the
restoration began
and that love
began to eclipse hate in the life of
this boy
i think healing's like that
it doesn't
usually come in a moment
usually it comes
a little bit at a time but it it has a
beginning
and as storytellers as filmmakers
we have the capacity to
aim the camera
aim the attention of the audience
at even the minutest movements
so that we are able to perceive
the moment
when
[Music]
a process of healing begins
and actually allow the audience to to
see feel and appreciate
what's happened
in a way that if we were on stage and we
were looking at the proscenium
like you'd miss it you'd never know what
was happening
we
we have the capacity to
uh to zoom in
on
these massively significant movements of
character that are almost imperceptible
somebody has said that the job of the
artist is to see
and then to show others what they've
seen
and for me this is an example of that of
looking closely enough
to see this
monumental thing that's happening
in this tiny little frame and blow that
up so that
we see it we understand it we
we appreciate its meaning and we feel it
and it seems that combination of meaning
and emotion are
another of the things that we
we just really crave from our stories
just out of curiosity what was the
leonardo dicaprio character doing
during that moment
he was
he was standing and watching he had
he had his assault rifle
and
i think he was ready to shoot the boy
if
he felt he needed to
uh but he was he was also witness he was
bearing witness to this
miracle moment
so even i haven't seen the film but
because his intentions sounds like they
were not that honorable either okay so
he but he's seeing this and do you see a
little bit of change in that character
at all yes yeah after that
he he discovers that actually he's been
shot in the fire fight that happened
just before this scene
he ends up
really sacrificing himself
to help father and son escape so yeah it
does actually
transform him to have witnessed this
moment